monsieur le ministre chers collègues
aujourd'hui les policiers sont dans la
rue suicide agression perte de sens de
leur mission
depuis vingt ans les gardiennes de la
paix n'avait pas crier aussi fort leur
rage rage à cause des violences qu'ils
subissent et qui restent impunis rage à
cause des heures supplémentaires qu'ils
donnent rage face à l'indifférence
générale lorsque l'on faut fonctionner
salies rage enfin quand ils se sentent
lâchés par les autorités monsieur le
ministre
ils ne sont pas les seuls les pompiers
les personnels des hôpitaux les
enseignants crient eux aussi leur
désespoir agressions violences verbales
et physiques menacent eux aussi sont
seuls pour affronter ces tensions
quotidiennes
enfin n'oublions pas les maires dont
nous avons tous vu cet été qu'il n'était
plus uniquement à porter d'engueulades
comme le dit notre président larcher
mais qu'ils sont désormais à portée de
coûts depuis des mois ces hommes et ces
femmes font face avec courage et
détermination
faute d'un soutien sans faille pour oser
aux événements que le gouvernement ne
sait pas maîtriser mais la résistance
humaine a ses limites
faute de réponse faute d'une colite
politique sans concession vis-à-vis de
la violence nous assistons à une perte
d'autorité sans précédent le sentiment
d'abandon par la puissance publique
dobbin or monsieur le ministre un état
qui ne protège pas ses serviteurs est un
navire sans boussole donc en perdition
monsieur le ministre
quelles sont les mesures immédiates que
vous allez prendre pour protéger des
forces de l'ordre dans l'exercice de
leurs fonctions quand déciderez-vous à
sanctionner ceux qui appellent à la
violence et à la mort envers tous ses
serviteurs qui incarne pourtant
l'autorité de la république